>> Tucker: THIS MIGHT BE THE
STRANGEST YEAR YET, BUT IT TURNS
OUT THE CHAOS HAS NOT STOPPED TO
THINK LIGHTS IN THE SKY.
ABOUT 100 SMALL WHITE ORBS WERE
HOVERING ABOVE.
WERE THEY BALLOONS OR BIRDS OR
SOMETHING BEFORE, WE DON’T KNOW.
WE MIGHT KNOW MORE IF WE HAD
MORE INFORMATION FROM THE
PENTAGON, THEY’VE BEEN STUDYING
YOUR PHOTOS CAREFULLY FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE.
BUT EVEN NOW THEY ARE KEEPING
WHAT THEY ARE FINDING TO
THEMSELVES AND THEMSELVES ONLY.
THERE APPEARS TO BE NO
SYSTEMATIC SHARING OF
INTELLIGENCE BETWEEN THE
PENTAGON AND INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES AND THAT’S VERY ODD.
AT LEAST AT LEAST CONCEIVABLY
UFOs MAY NOT BE FROM SPACE.
ALTHOUGH THE PENTAGON BELIEVES
THIS, THEY THINK THEY ARE FROM
SPACE BUT IN THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY THAT COULD BE FROM
CHINA OR ANOTHER ONE OF THIS
COUNTRY’S ENEMIES, SO WE SHOULD
FIND OUT.
THIS WEEK THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE TOOK A
STEP TOWARDS FIXING THAT AND
VOTED TO REQUIRE THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT TO COMPILE AND
RELEASE A DETAILED REPORT
RELEASING EVERYTHING IT KNOWS
ABOUT UNEXPLAINED IMPERIAL
PHENOMENON.
WE HOPE THAT HAPPENS, WE HAVE NO
FAITH THAT IT ACTUALLY WILL BUT
WE ARE ROOTING FOR IT.
AND YOU HAVE HEARD IT HERE
FIRST.
FOR MANY YEARS, PEOPLE HAVE SAID
IT’S JUST UFOs CRAZINESS.